if you're G to work on sales techniques
alone you're only going so far unless
you are just a complete Beast that is so
highly driven that you can push through
your own programs but even people who do
that I've noticed coming up they many of
them became multi-millionaires and then
they end up losing it so what I find
myself doing a lot today is helping
people to remove that sort of sabotage
pattern and I call a battlefield surgery
a lot of times they get hurt on the
field I got to I got to put them back in
and boom get them back out as quick as I
can skills are great and they will get
you to a certain point but you know your
mindset or you know maybe your body set
your nervous system uh will put your
skill set on
steroids Mark is here he's a new member
of Movie Makers and part of that we're
doing an Instagram live together what's
on your mind man how can I help I joined
this program uh I really like the uh the
bizdev show in order to uh you know in
order to grow the business already got
my first uh show booked with Ben Gay III
he's the author of The closers series of
books which sold 10 million copies I'm
actually one of his co-authors I did I
did book five with him Master the the en
closer mindset so for sales sales-driven
entrepreneur six six figure sales people
so essentially I'm going down the road
and I'm I'm doing this program I would
say the big problem I have in the
program is is just understanding
Discord
okay but uh it it no it's all good I'm
I'm in progress and I'm just taking the
action steps along the way so
everything's actually on on track uh I'm
gonna book a call every single week with
somebody else I know who my market is
I'm I'm working on getting to uh sixf
figure commission salespeople I've got
some uh some great names on my list that
we're pursuing and uh we'll be doing a a
call a week in uh 2024 so I love it and
are you doing are you doing big name
only or you also doing people that
you're going to be coaching oh oh no
it'll be well it's my understanding is
and maybe this is a good time for the
question um I'm starting with Ben only
because he's a he's the oldest living
sales Legend and and I uh co-authored a
book with him as well he's he's he's big
in front of in front of the market but
um no I'll be dealing with all sorts of
people I've identified uh who have large
sales teams and so essentially whether
they're well-known or not as long as
they have you know a a sales team uh
that essentially could be referred
that's that's kind of the idea yeah I
mean and that's the main thing that
you're upleveling people with their
sales skills well I'm kind of an
integrated sales trainer so when skills
when uh sales skills no longer work for
people they got all the skills and they
can't figure out why they're Contracting
that's where I come in but I do teach
sales skills uh I have a process
proprietary process I created called
guard down selling um and so there's
certain processes I teach uh this was
born out of necessity running my own
companies but then what I noticed um
through the years is that people would
continue to contract or they would have
sales slumps and so that's where the
sort of integrated approach came in and
where I you know sort of address the
past and what those blocks might be and
you know their nervous system and how
it's shutting them down skills are great
and they will get you to a certain point
but you know your mindset or you know
maybe your body set your nervous system
uh will put your skill set on steroids
got it and this content is going to live
on your YouTube channel yeah well the
content I'm doing with uh what we're
doing here movement makers yes that'll
live on YouTube I also have a private um
a private group called The Million dooll
sales Pro I've got a free Facebook group
and so there's content on there there'll
be content as YouTube I've just
reestablished my YouTube I've currently
got uh 616 followers coming into this so
that's yeah that's pretty cool and
that's before I ever did anything I'm
excited the first 616 is the hardest 616
so it's only up from here the bizde show
is amazing and imagine if you're talking
to one
ideal client or referral partner every
week and they're getting to know you yep
I mean that could 10x your business in
the next year I mean and it's so much
easier to get them to talk to you now
you're a great salesman so uh you know
how to close and convert which is great
because a lot of people struggle with
that when they're right when they're on
their path uh and the challenge is just
getting in front of qualified prospects
and having a conversation where it's not
just a hey do you want to go out for
coffee but you're interviewing them
you're having conversation you know
you're building Rapport creating a
relationship and then it's easy to do
the next follow-up step and if you're
talking to sales departments again this
is probably the only time they've ever
been interviewed for anything so it's
pretty easy to find out who they are and
to get them to say yes because you're
flattering them and you're giving them
piece of content for themselves right
and if you were trying to get to the CEO
of Coca-Cola or something it might be a
lot more challenging but for the people
who are the decision makers for you it's
a lot easier so I like I mean that's a
great show that's a great cadence once a
week the demonstrate the process is
where coaches can really shine where
you're showing the process of you doing
the thing without breaking it down when
you're working with people you help them
get these aha moments and breakthroughs
yep that if somebody else were to look
at it looks like
magic right from the outside if they
just sat in and watched you do this it'd
be like how is he doing this when I'm
coaching people oneon-one let's say it's
on a zoom I should be uh documenting all
that and using you know clips from that
to to also post on YouTube as well if
you already have it are you going and
doing coaching inside your Facebook
group I do not coach inside the Facebook
group so I have a private uh members
Group which I have currently so the
Facebook I just go and I do I do these
lives so there's content there but not
me demonstrating the process up to this
point it's been you know off the cuff so
I I run my own company so coaching to me
has been you know sort of a side hustle
I own a solar systems company and um
okay yeah so but I love coaching so I do
a lot of it and I'm good at it this is
the year I'm really organizing
everything so on Facebook right now you
know I've never done I've never done a
um like had somebody else on there with
me um so that you know would probably be
something I would do this year or I do
do a lot of coaching I do a ton of it
every single day and I could I could
record those and then you know break up
those uh and put them out there yeah I
mean ideally you'd put out the whole
session not just a little clip it'll
perform better if I get to understand
the story and the and see the whole you
know transition with somebody what do it
cost to be in your group currently while
I'm in beta 197 a month and 997 down
what's that group called again it's
called the million doll salespro and my
be called the million dooll salespro
show I
likeing so what you could do is say for
the people who are in million dooll in
the million dollar sales program right
now that you're launching a new YouTube
show where you're G to be coaching
people
one-on-one and it's free but it's going
to go on to YouTube and so it's not some
bait and switch afterwards and you're
surprised this is going to go on YouTube
they know in advance right but you say
that access to Mark is is really
difficult and very expensive yep to get
one onone time with Mark is is not
possible or it's going to be very very
expensive but you're going to get it for
free because you're part of this program
ah I like that the million dollar sales
Pro and who wants it and you have people
who who say yes y they put up their
hands say hey please pick me I like so
now when they come on you say hey here's
John he's part of our million dollar
sales Pro now what's the million dollar
sales now we're talking about it without
it being a sales pitch right and then
hopefully John says something good like
oh my God Mark your million dollar sales
Pro is my favorite program right you say
great and then you say okay John how can
I help and then John tells you where
he's struggling and then you just help
him you don't you don't need tons of
prep work or you know an entire dossier
on John you just show up and you know he
wants to sell and he's stuck somewhere
and then you go solve his problem so I
was a little concerned with that because
I can modu
you know how deep I want to coach people
I could either sort of snorkel or scuba
dive depending um but some of my scuba
diving stuff I was a little sort of
apprehensive to put that out there
because it gets into some some deeper
things especially like I give you an
example let's say A
salesperson is writing a lot of deals
and they keep canceling so they're
coming to me with a pattern right so
let's just say they wrote five deals and
five deals cancel and they're really
upset about it so I know that this
person has uh a belief in let's say
disappointment so they're recreating
disappointment unconsciously so for me
to get to the cause of that to get to
the root of that I might take them
through a process where I'm taking you
know close your eyes put your hand on
your heart I'm taking them back to a
certain place I'm looking for the root
cause of that and I kid you not this is
so
predictable for I've done this so many
times thousands of times I can read the
pattern I bring them back to a time
where unconsciously that is reminding
them of something I clear that with them
and they will call me within 48 hours
you're not gonna I just had one right
before you got on said he did it we we
did the clearing last week said he just
had his biggest deal biggest Commission
of the entire year today it's repeatable
for me it happens over and over again
but I didn't know how deep I should go
into that because sometimes we get into
some stuff sometimes people are crying
and you know different things happen as
we're going back so my whole strategy is
about integrated it's an integrated
strategy if you're G to work on sales
techniques alone you're only going so
far unless you are just a complete Beast
that is so highly
driven that that you can push through
your own programs but even people who do
that I've noticed coming up they many of
them became multi-millionaires and then
they end up losing it so what I find
myself doing a lot today is helping
people to remove that sort of sabotage
pattern and I call it Battlefield
surgery a lot of times they get hurt on
the field I gotta I gotta put them back
in and boom get them back out there as
quick as I can so I I guess my ultimate
question on that is is that okay to just
go as deep as I normally go and show it
yeah the two concerns are either one
they may not go there with you you know
or sometimes two is like am I showing
too much of my IP for anybody on the
internet to be able to see right right
which one of those two or both is a
concern probably more about showing you
know the vulnerability of the
process so for for for your for your the
member that you're coaching that's right
y yeah so a couple things then one
they're already in your tribe yes so
they they know what you talk about yes
so if they're in the million dollar
sales Pro you're you're covering some of
these things already you're not just
staying surface level and teaching them
different closes right so they they know
that this is your world already so it's
not some giant bait and switch in the
call to in the email or or talking about
the live stream or inside your group you
can say we're going to go deep you like
I want this is a free session for you
but we're going to go deep and we're
going to cover your hidden traumas and
the reason why these this is a repeated
pattern for you and this is why it's so
expensive to work with Mark and you're
going to get it absolutely for free but
don't sign up if you want to stay at
surface level this is a this is we're
going deep we're going to Deep dive I
don't want to snorkel with you we're GNA
scuba dive together and then it's also
for anybody else who has that same
problem I want them to be inspired by
your story so that it's it's switching
to service mindset for them as well it's
not just a selfish thing that other
people can learn from it and that
handles most of the situations now if
somebody is just absolutely falling
apart it's like ple I can't believe I
said that about my mom please don't put
that you can use your discretion and
judgment to cut that part out or not
post it but most of the time like I've
done tons of coaching with people and um
most of the time there's no problem and
the the the main thing here is that
you're you're not trying to make them
look bad you're trying to help that's
right so if people will go on Dr Phil
and Jerry Springer and punch each other
and you know all the things they do
there where like it's trying to get this
gotcha moment to make them all hate each
other they will come on your show where
you're actually trying to support them
and help them right you know what what
you do is not just leave them in the
trauma you pull them out to the other
side oh yeah 100% y so great like you're
leaving them on a high like oh my God
Mark just changed my life oh they have
such ridiculous aha experiences when I
do it because they can't connect the the
current struggle or challenge to a root
cause and that's what I'm able to do
very quickly is to just very fast see
that help them see it it's based off
Carl Yung when you make the he has a
quote that says until the unconscious
becomes conscious it will direct your
life and you will call it fate and so
what I do is I make the unconscious
conscious so it doesn't direct your life
so therefore they can create their
Destiny of their choosing
so so this is a something that then I
would keep private how you do the method
yep is your secret sauce that does not
get revealed on YouTube videos and
public content okay where it's based off
Carl Young and all the steps that you do
you want to be the magician who was
making magic happen but you don't know
where that Dove came from
right so you could say the results of
like hey the the example you shared
right now recently that guy was blocked
and now he just got his is biggest sales
commission of all time like amazing and
surface of of like hey I help find the
repeated patterns it's probably based in
some trauma and if you don't fix this
it'll continue to happen so I'm the guy
who's going to find those repeated
patterns and remove it so you can forge
a new life going forward like that's
basically as much detail as you share
unless your goal is to train other
people how to do
this then we don't want to go too deep
into the breaking down of how you do it
right gotcha based on Carl Young and
make sure you hold your hand on the
heart and make whatever you do you're
just going to make it look like magic
but the magician doesn't reveal the
secrets gotcha unless you join you know
the M Sales Pro right or you hire me to
come speak at your thing what are your
thoughts about playlist so obviously
you're recommending three different
shows of bis Dev demonstrate your
process in a social media influencer of
sorts and so should I have like three
playlists or no play playlist and it's
just everything under Mark toy you could
have three playlists but most people
don't consume by playlists but it just
helps organize it so that when I hit
your YouTube page it'll show me three
different types of content yes the
thought leadership content is probably
the least important for you especially
at the start that's where you're just
speaking direct to camera right so the
bizde show gets you clients like you
don't even need to grow your social
presence for you to 10x your business
just from relationships that you create
right and that's in the bizde show it's
not about making you look good it's
about making your guests look good so
that you can create a relationship to
then work with their sales team right
right and so those videos don't
necessarily have to have tons of views
the ROI is the relationship that you
just created that's right the coaching
show the show me the process show is
usually the best show to make if you're
good at coaching like the caveat is if
you suck at
coaching you get exposed it's like if
they came and brought you this problem
he's like oh I don't know what to do
with that then that that's a problem
right but if if you're good and you have
a deep well of knowledge it's actually
the best show because it's usually the
most fun to create because you're
actually helping somebody you're not
just talking in your house to a camera
um and it shows off how good you are
because there's lots of people who can
talk a big game what you just said I
could say too I could say here's what
here's what we do we got to uncover your
child TR we got to find the repeater
patterns that have hold held I could say
all the things said but it doesn't mean
that I can go and do what you do that's
right and so there's lots of and
especially in the sales world there's a
lot of sales coaches and trainers who
can talk a great game but then when
they're face to face with a with a
client who's struggling with sale they
don't know what to do or how to help
that's right that and that's that's sort
of my unique positioning because I I
don't I coach out of necessity I'm a
business guy I run companies I have 200
employees I have 50 salespeople so I've
gotta I've got to do Battlefield surgery
and I've been doing it for three decades
that's where this all came out of the
battlefield surgery if if I don't do it
correctly you know my companies would
never have made it and uh my most recent
company we we literally hit the Inc 5000
at number 14 in 20 in 2021 so that's
when I started to realize that wow I
could take this out to a broader
audience and so um that's kind of a
unique positioning uh in the second
unique positioning is the integrated
approach you can beat people with sales
skills all day it's only going to take
them so far because their nervous system
eventually is going to show up and it's
going to contract because that's what
nervous systems do that's just sort of
what makes it a little bit unique yeah
no I mean you're you're my favorite kind
of people to work with because you're
actually really good at what you do yep
but the world doesn't know it yet and so
that's right that that's that's the
whole model so let's show it I feel like
I feel like Eminem before he came out
with Slim
Shady well uh you could do a wrap as
well I don't know if I can help you too
much with your rap song but uh terms of
thought leadership content coaching
content we can make that happen for sure
y so I'd love to see a show a week of
the bisf that's a little harder to book
so if you have your team or assistant
whoever helping you kind of reach out to
people y um the coaching show the show
me the process show again could be team
and that you could do all together right
like if you if you the goal is one a
week you could take two hours on the
Monday morning or Thursday afternoon or
whatever and put four people half an
hour back to back to back to back right
and whether that's you or just someone
on the team messaging the people in the
Facebook group to say hey who wants some
one-on-one time with Mark right and then
you just book them all together those
are usually pretty easy to do um and
then if you wanted to do a thought
leadership show where that's more direct
to camera you can as well but like right
now I'm not even I'm not even tuned into
that at all I I love the when I saw
Business Development I knew right away
that's that's my that's that's the
strategy I'm going to use and I know I
can do it I feel comfortable with it I
just love the whole thing and I'm just
gonna I'm a hockey player you're from
Canada you must be familiar with hockey
I'm from Massachusetts originally we
didn't play hockey my whole life so my
point is you got to skate your lane you
know unless you're a center and uh you
gotta you gotta skate your lane yeah I
was about to say I don't know too many
hockey players from Florida and that was
their number one sport yeah y Boston
makes a lot more sense yep original six
I love it um cool so I mean the next
step really is just making sure that you
get the shows
booked that you're doing the Outreach uh
and then after that usually we're we're
jumping into the actual sales process
with people but I don't have to teach
you how to sell and follow up and close
deals yeah yeah that part that part's
easy so it's really just uh identifying
who the right people are and then
inviting them on the show to have a
great conversation yep should I like I
give you an example one of the people
that I'm gonna get a show with um I I
want to make sure I'm not going like too
big maybe maybe you know you could speak
into that so one of them is um the owner
of a probably the largest solar company
in the nation so it would be like the
CEO of that company and I want to
develop a relationship with that person
is that too big should I be going after
you know like more the I don't know
maybe the Vice President of Sales who's
got 20 people you know reporting to them
or or what what are your thoughts on
that well I mean the the largest solar
company in the country the vice
president would have more than 20 salesp
people reporting to him oh no no no I
know he this guy's got thousands well
well they're trying to enter into
relationship with my Solar Company
because they want us to do some of their
installs so like I'm already in touch
with these people I can get right to the
CEO yeah so go for it like even if the
CEO is not in charge of the decision
yeah if the CEO says we're going to work
with Mark then it's done yeah um I guess
I I don't want to like overshoot it with
you know uh too big of the elephants and
just I don't know maybe that's what I
was wondering if you could speak into
the the biggest thing is just thinking
well one if you have a relationship is a
lot easier than going in cold right he
might do it just because he knows you
and he likes you and this now now you're
you're just flattering him right I mean
the idea that you would on do an
interview with him we're not selling
anything we're just building a
relationship creating content is usually
an easy yes the next is how many
opportunities are coming to them for
this kind of stuff so if it was hey let
me Pitch you on this he's getting
pitched a thousand times a day from all
kinds of vendors and all sorts of
different things right the last thing he
needs at another sales pitch how many
people are pitching him to tell his
story and hear and do an interview with
him nobody probably probably not a lot y
but the CEO of Coca-Cola is probably
getting lots of media requests that
they're saying no to right so that's the
that's the the Judgment line if they're
not getting a lot of requests now you're
media and now it's a lot easier to get a
yes and to build a relationship so you
could go higher up there's nothing wrong
with starting that CEO and if they say
no or you don't hear back go one step
down to the VP of sales right for the
organization gotcha okay yeah it makes
sense I'm just you know I'm I'm kind of
a hit first ask questions later I love
it but I'm trying to I'm trying to look
before I leap a little bit here so I'm
I'm just absorbing the content and doing
my level best to uh take the actions
based on my understanding of what I
should do cool man well welcome board
mve makers great to have you and can't
wait to see this uh show get off the
ground sounds good thanks so much for uh
for taking the questions all right much
love Mark okay bye cheers to watch me
coach another Mastermind member
oneon-one check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there I like trying to figure out how to
make $2,000 a month 2,000 a month only
2,000 per client if you could make 2,000
a month per client or you have you know
basically $8,000 coming in every month
you basically have a six- figure
business